hooray and finally he's human and now we  got a fight they're legitimate fighting  [Applause]  and this is still the  the basket standard  [Applause]  Ramon's involved  these are gone  have one technical  this stefank dr seemed like just a  normal day good d fish you got the ball  away develop this  [Applause]  dreama's jerseys ripped  on the other side right there  [Applause]  he already has one tea so that he will  be gone  [Applause]  and this is where they'll go to replay  and  [Applause]  new driving is the one involved  and Jim said it he finally mr. three  have been perfect for a toy let's see  dream on set the baseline Oh what was  that he got wrapped around the neck I  don't know whether he took an elbow  first let's see that they